[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر البركه
احييكم واليكم العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من
كل زواياه هو من جميع جوانبه
بولندا لكن
بعد اعلان الترشح طريق ترامب للرئاسه تمر
عبر حزب منقسم وقضاء مستنفر والصخره بسنتس
[موسيقى]
مقتلته احكام الاعدام فطالوا ثلاثه
محتاجين في ايران واضراب روح طهران
البازار يضاعف ازمه النظام
ولدينا ايضا في العربيه 360 بعد اضخم
هجومين على اراضيها استراليا تصل لخلاصه
الحرب ضد القراصنه لا تنتظرهم قرصنهم
تنفس العالم السعداء اليوم بعد ان حبس
انفسه ليله امس على اثر سقوط صاروخ على
الاراضي الهولنديه فهذا هو الشبح الذي
يخشاه الجميع اعتداء روسي على اراضي دوله
فنيته يجبر الحلف على دخول الحرب اليوم
المؤشرات تصب في اتجاه اوكرانيا الصاروخ
الذي سقط بشكل
عن تطبيق البند الرابع
لكن جرس الانذار يدق عاليا فالظروف مهيئه
طالما بقيه الحرب اذ بدات تركيزه الان على
تزويد بولندا بانظمه الدفاع الجوي رغم ان
اوروبا باكملها تواجه عزا في هذه المنظمات
اوكرانيا لها راي اخر بعد ما اثارته من
ضجه في الساعات الاخيره
او كوفي موسكو وراء القصف وحتى بعد ان مال
الغرب تجاه روسيا تريد كيف ان تعيده
للروايه الاولى طلب سكرتير مجلس الامن
القومي والدفاع الاوكراني الاكسيداني لوف
وصول بلاده الفوري لموقع الضربه لكن
بولندا ردت عليه واشنطن هي التي تقرر ذلك
في كل الاحوال وبعيدا عن مساعي اوكرانيا
فان الجدل حول الصاروخ انتهى نسبيا باعلان
من الرئيس البولندي اندريادوده
ظهر الرئيس مع رئيسي وزراهه ليؤكد ان
المعلومات تشير الى ان الصاروخ سوف ياتي
الصنع من طراز اف 3 وان لا دليل على
اطلاقه من روسيا وانه في الاغلب تم اطلاقه
من منظومه دفاعيه اوكرانيه
لا يوجد ما يشير الى ان الضربه الصاروخيه
كانت تستهدف البلاد في عمل متعمد اما رئيس
الوزراء
على ان بلاده لم تطلب تفعيل الماده
الرابعه من ميثاق نيته التي تطيح بدا
مشاورات فيما اذا كانت تهديد موجوده
وكيفيه مواجهته
لكن الامر لا يحتمل التهاون فاموراوسكي
اوضح ان بلاده ستعزز وجود قواتها وقوات
الناتو على الحدود الشرقيه
[موسيقى]
الدفاع الجوي والاوكراني اطلق الصواريخ
لتحديد هذا الهجوم الروسي تشير تقديرات
الى انه تم اسقاط النصف الصواريخ الروسيه
الاوكرانيه لسوء الحظ من المحتمل جدا ان
يكون احد الصواريخ التي اطلقتها الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه قد سقط على اراضينا
والارجح انه لم يكن انفجارا للصاروخ نفسه
لكن من المحتمل لانه كان انفجارا للوقود
المتبقي فيه ربما يكون صاروخ اس 3 صنع في
الاتحاد السوفياتي وهو صاروخ قديم ولا
يوجد دليل على انه مطلق من الجانب الروسي
وعقد اجتماع عن طارئا احرف بشان الصاروخ
والذي كان الغموض يحيط بمصده وقت الاستماع
بعد الاجتماع ايد الامين العام للحلف ينس
طولكرم برج روايه بولندا واكد انه
اللامراشرات على ان سقوط الصاروخ كان عملا
هجوميا متعمدا لكن في كل الاحوال ستبقى
روسيا مولاما ولو بشكل غير مباشره بحسب
ستوتنبرج فكثافه صواريخها واستمرار الحرب
الدالي لهذا الحدث
انه الجيش انسان التحقيق في هذا الحديث
مستمر ونحن بحاجه الى انتظار نتائج لكن
ليس لدينا ما يشير الى ان هذا كان نتيجه
هجوم متعمد وليس لدينا ما يشير الى ان
روسيا تستعد لعمليات عسكريه هجوميه ضد
الناس تحليلنا الاولي يشير الى ان الحادثه
كان على الارجح بسبب صاروخ دفاع جوي
اوكراني تم اطلاقه للدفاع عن الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ضد هجمات صواريخ كروز الروسيه
لكن قولي ان اوضح هذا ليس خطا اوكرانيا
روسيا تتحمل المسؤوليه النهائيه لانها
تواصل حربها غير القانونيه ضد اوكرانيا
لكن بشكل عام كان لافتا ان العواصم
الغربيه التي سارعت لابداء الدعم لبولندا
دعت الى التزام الحذر بشان تحديد مصدر
القذيفه حتى ان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
منذ البدايه راى انه من غير المحتمل ان
اطلاق الصاروخ الذي اصاب بولندا اطلق من
روسيا
بس دقيقه
روسيا التي شددت على اللا علاقه لها
بالحادث منذ البدايه التقطت تصريحات بيدن
ورحبت بضط النفس من الجانب الامريكي بينما
ردد الكاملين بما وصفه بالهستيريا من طرف
مسؤولين كبار لدول عده واعتبر ان
تصريحاتهم لم تقم على بيانات حقيقيه
تابعنا ذلك في اخبار عاجله بالامس في
العربيه 360 اذا تذكرون لكن ماذا عن باقي
ردود الفعل الغربيه المانيا اقترح الدعم
بولندا بدوريات جويه بعد سقوط صاروخ على
اراضي الاخيره وقال المتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع الالمانيه ان برلين ستعرض على ورشه
تسيير دوريات جويه مع مقاتلات يورو فايتر
الالمانيه
فقد دعت على لساني رئيسها الى تدعيم
للجبهه الشرقيه
بمنظمات الدفاع جويه للتصدي لروسيا
[موسيقى]
ليتوانيا ستدعم وستشارك في المناقشات
وسنتحدث عن نشر منظومات الدفاع الجوي على
الحدود البولنديه الاوكرانيه وكل الجناح
الشرقي للنيتو اذكركم انه خلال قمه الناتو
في مدريد قبل بضعه اشهر توصلنا لاهميه نشر
المنظومه في الجناح الشرقيه للحلو»
والحادث الذي شاهدناه في بولندا يجعلنا
نفكر في كيفيه تنفيذ ذلك بسرعه البيانات
لن تنفع التنفيذ سيساعدنا على الدفاع عن
انفسنا
لكن حتى انتفاد الناتو الانزلاق نحو الرد
المباشر هذه المره فما هي الظروف التي قد
تدفعه لذلك في المستقبل
السيناريو الابرز هو هجوم روسيا على دوله
عضو بالنيتو بشكل مباشره اي ان يتكرر حادث
الامس ولكن بشكل متعمد من روسيا سواء ضد
بولندا او ضد دول اخرى في نيته احتمال اخر
هو اذا استهدفت روسيا قافله امداد عسكريه
غربيه لدى عبورها من احدى دول الناتو
حينها ايضا يتم تفعيل الماده الخامسه من
ميثاق النيدو المتعلقه بالدفاع المشترك
سيناريو اخير هو ان يؤدي القتال الى وقوع
انفجار في منشاه صناعيه مع اطلاق غازات
كيميائيه سامه تؤثر مثلا على اوكرانيا او
تصل باثارها الى النت الى دول النيته يبدو
هذا الاحتمال الاضعف لكنه يظل قائما
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك معنا ضيفا استاذ مشاري بنعزم
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من باريس تنضم
الينا لمناقشه هذا الموضوع وابدا معك
فكره ان العالم كان على شفا حرب عالميه
ثالثه لو ما وصفته روسيا
روسيا وليس غير روسيا بالرصانه الموقف
الرصيد للولايات المتحده
والنيتو ما الذي حصل هل كان هناك جناح ما
يريد همم للنيته ان يدخل في هذه الحرب ام
ان هناك بوادر ايجابيه كان هذا الجناح
يريد تنصها من خلال بدء التفاوض بين
الطرفين
نعم ان نكون انه حقيقه ان العالم قد تحاشا
الانزلاق الى حرب بين قوتين ككلتهما
النوويه اي روسيا من جهه والحلف الاطلسي
من جهه اخرى باعتبار ان بولندا عضو في
الاطلسي وانه ينطبق عليها البندان رقم
اربعه والرقم 5 خصوصا البنت الخامس الذي
يلزم كافه الدول الحلف الاطلسي ل ااه
النجده بولندا او اي طرف اخر يكون محل
تهديد ملاحظه اولى الملاحظه الثانيه
وتحديدا في مخصص سؤالك يعني لو راينا كافه
التعليقات والتصريحات والتحليلات التي
حصلت والنتائج التي توصل اليها الخبراء
منذ امس وحتى اليوم نجد ان الجميع استبعد
فرضيه ان تكون روسيا هي التي
ارسلت هذا الصاروخ الذي وقع في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه واريد ان اضيف ان اا مكان وقوع
هذا الصاروخ لا يبعد سوا 12 كلم عن الحدود
الاوكرانيه
اذا الاستثناء الوحيد كان هو بولندا
الرئيس الرئيس ظل عفوا اوكراني الرئيس
جيلنسكي بعد دقائق قليله من سقوط هذا
الصاروخ اتهم روسيا مباشره لبن ما زال
يتهممها اليوم رغما رغم
الاطلسيه الامريكيه الاوروبيه وايضا
البولنديه التي تقول ان هذا غير مقصود
ولكن هناك ايضا همم سبب تقني اريد ان
اتوقف عنده دقيقه لو سمحت انا موجود هو
بقايا صاروخ اس 300
والجميع يعلم ان صاروخ اس 3 هو صاروخ دفاع
جوي فكيف يمكن ان تكون روسيا هي التي
اطلقت هذا الصاروخ وسقط في بولندا علما
انه يستخدم فقط ضد الطائرات او المسيرات
او الصواريخ
البالستيه وغير البلاستيكيه تمام اليوم
يمكن ان نعتبر حقيقه ان ترى ما حصل خلال
الساعات الاخيره جنب
عالم المواجهه ولكن ليس علينا ان نغالي في
ذلك يعني حتى حتى لو افترضنا ان الصاروخ
كان اطلق من روسيا لا ليس من المؤكد ان
هذا العالم كان سيذهب حقيقه المواجهه لان
هناك درجات في التصعيد قبل الوصول الى
المواجهه العسكريه صحيحه وهناك درجات ايضا
من
الاجراءات التي يجب ان تتخذ
درس وقوع العالم في هذه الستيريا التي وقع
فيها بالامس همم الوصف الروسي يدين بعض
دول الجوار وما قام به بالامس عبر قادته
ولكن فعلا لو رايت المشهد همم اعلاميا
بالامس في العالم اجمع همم كان
سهير اعلاميه فيما يتعلق
باستنادا الى التصريحات التي كانت تصدر من
قاده هذه الدول كيف يمكن ان نصنف لنا همم
كيف يمكن ان يصنف الاداء السياسي اقصد
وليس علامه بعد ما حصل من تصريحات كانت
تتبنى وتؤكد همم روسيه الصاروخ وضروره
اتخاذ الاجراءات العاجله
نعم المشكله اليوم ان العالم اصبح مقسوما
للقسمين القسم الاول هو الداعم من غير
حدود ولا شروطانيا ومهما حصل كان في
اوكرانيا او في الجوار الاوكراني تكون
المسؤوليه لروسيا والقسم الثاني له نظره
مختلفه يعني لا يمكن تبريه روسيا في
المحصله روسيا هي التي قامت بالحرب على
اوكرانيا منذ 24 فبراير الماضي روسي
المنشات المدنيه روسيا هي التي تحتلت
اراده التي خسرتها وتراجعت عنها والى غير
ذلك ولكن اليوم السؤال هو هل كان من مصلحه
روسيه هذا هو السؤال هل كان من مصلحه
روسيه في ان همم توجه صواريخها الى دوله
تتمتع بالحمايه بالمظله الامريكيه
والاطلسيه يعني الجواب بالطبع كلا لان
روسيا حتى داخل حتى داخل اوكرانيا غير
قادره على المحافظه على موقعها دفاعيا
فلماذا سوف تنخرط في حرب مع الدول القاسيه
التي بينها دول تمام المتحده وفرنسا
وبريطانيا وغيرها هذه هي ملاحظه الاولى
الملاحظه الثانيه
منذ بدء الحرب اي في في قبل تسعه اشهر او
10 اشهر بدا هذه الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا كان همم التعاطي معها همم لا
ياخذ بعين الاعتبار التفاصيل بمعنى انه من
هو مع اوكرانيا لا ياخذ بعين الاعتبار ما
يستطر عن اطراف اخرى
حتى مثلا المعلومات الخاصه باعداد الضحايا
هل لديك عزيزي همم هل لديك اليوم عدد حول
الضحايا الاوكرانيه ليس هنا كان عدد هل
لديك حول الضحيه المدنيه
على ما اعتقد انك تشارك نعم معلش انا اسف
ان اكتفي بهذا
الكاتب السياسي من باريس بس لانه انتهى
وقتنا حبه ووضح للمجاهدين ايضا ما كنت
تقصده شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
معقوله معكم نتابع ايضا في العربيه 360
منتجع مره لاجو يشهد اعلان ترشح ترامب
لكنه قد يكون سببا في نهايه مستقبله
السياسي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى الولايات المتحده
حيث لا يمكن اعتبار ترشح ترامب لسباق
الرئاسه مفاجئا فالرجل اصلا هو ملك
المفاجات واسمه لم يغب عن الساحه حتى حين
هزم وتولد جو بيدنس ضد الحكم في يناير من
العام الماضي ومن داخل مقر اقامته في
منتجع مره لاغو بولايت فلوريدا اشعل ترامب
فتيله سباق 2024 وقف الرجل 76 عاما معلنا
بقى ترشحه في خطاب استمر اكثر من ساعه هذه
المره كانت استراتيجيته ومسبطا على
انتقاده ادارات غريبه ايضا وتعديد اسباب
فشلها من وجهه
[موسيقى]
ياباني تصنع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
سبايدر مان
[تصفيق]
الى حافه حرب النوويه بسبب موقفه من
الازمه الاوكرانيه مجددا دعوته لمؤيده
لنجعل امريكا عظيمه مره اخرى
شو يرزقه
[تصفيق]
مراكز باي باي
فقد اعتبر ان ترامب خذل امريكا وانه خلال
رئاسته تربع على اقتصاد مزور لصالح
الاثرياء وهاجم النظام الصحي ودلل
المتطرفين وهجمه حقوق المراه وحرض
العصابات العنيفه في كل الاحوال
ستكون مختلفه عن سابقتيها كثيرا فاغلب
دائرته الضيقه لم تعد موجوده ابنته
ايفانكا اعرضت عن دعمها لها طبعا لكنها
اكدت انها ستختار هذه المره اعطاء
الاولويه لاطفالها ولحياتها الخاصه هذا
فضلا عن انقسام الجمهوريين حول شخصه خاصه
بعد النتائج الضعيفه التي سجلها في
انتخابات التجديد النصفي فضلا عن ان اكثر
من جمهوري تراوده احلام الترشح اكثر
الوجه الاكثر جاذبيه الان في الحزب حتى
القنوات الاخباريه اتخذت موقفا غير معتاد
من ترامب مثلا
خطابه كاملا واشارتا الى انهما ستعودان
اليه اذا استدعى الامر ذلك
سيكون على ترامب اذا ان يستدعي نجاحاته
السابقه في المكتب البيضاوي اهمها شعبيه
لدى المحافظين خاصه بعد تعييناته لقضاه
المحكمه العليا
وتخفيضات الضريبيه الكاسحه التي سنها فضلا
عن رعايته لاتفاقات سلام في الشرق الاوسط
وقت الزعيم تنظيم داعش ابو بكر البغدادي
لكن لا شيء مضمون بالنسبه لترامب قبل ان
يفصل القضاء في الاتهامات المواجهه اليها
طبعا احداث الكابتل وتحريض المتظاهرين في
المقدمه والتعامل غير المدروس مع الكورونا
وتراجع دور الولايات المتحده ايضا لا ننسى
ملف الوثائق السريه والملاحقات الضريبيه
لعائلته كل هذه الملفات قد تؤدي في
النهايه لاستبعاده هذا ان لم ينجو كما نجع
من محاولات عزله وهو رئيس
[موسيقى]
معنى من واشنطن امال مدلليه سفير
اللبنانيه سابقه الامم المتحده اهلا بك
معنا سعد السفيره في العربيه 360 طبعا
البعض متى يعتبر بان لدى ترامب او امامه
معركه جمهوريه جمهوريه قبل ان ينتقل
النجاح الى معركته الثانيه مع الحزب
المضاد الحزب الديمقراطي الى اي مدى
توافقين على انه حظوظه باتت ضعيفه امام
نجوم اخرين في الحزب الان مثل بيسان
الواقع ان هذا يبدو صحيحا الان بالرغم من
ان الرئيس ترامب السابقه
استفتاءات على 47% من الجمهوريين الذين
يصودون ولكن
اسراعه في وضع اسمه للانتخابات 2020 هو
دليل على انه خائف من الوضع داخل الجمهوري
والتحدي الذي يواجهه خصوصا الجديد في
الحزب والواقع كما ذكرته في التقرير انه
ليس ايضا ليس فقط انه خلال اعلانه لترشحه
مره اخرى همم يبدو انه ضعيف وان الكثيرين
من الدائره الصغيره او مصغره الذي كانت
حوله ولا بعيد
بما فيهم ابنته ولكن ايضا وهذا الاهم ان
لمواليد الكبار لحملته السابقين ينسحبون
ويبتعدون عنه الواحد بعد الاخر وهذا امر
هام جدا لان المال مهم جدا في الحملات
الانتخابيه الامريكيه
بحزب الجمهوري منقسم الان هناك همم معركه
محتدمه حول رئاسه همم حول الرئاسه في
الكونجرس رئاسه الحزب والان اليوم فقط
راينا ان نجم قنال اللي هو زعيم زعيم
الجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ قد ربح معركه
ضد ريكس قاتل الذي يعتبر من المقربين من
ترامب في الانتخابات في الكونجرس وهو الان
سيعود كالرئيس
للجمهوريين وهذا دليل على ان همم جميع
الذين دعموا ترامب همم لم يعودوا لديهم
القدره كمادات السابق على تولي المناصب
وكما ايضا
نتائج التي يعني يمكن وصفها بانه ليست
نتائج التي ارادها على حسب الجمهوري على
الاقل ان لم نقل نتائج ضعيفه باعتقادك ومن
خلال شخصيه ترامب هل سيكون جاهزا لدراسه
هذه العقبات والصفات التي تلقاها ولمحاوله
تخطيها اما عدم الاعتراف
بالواقع الذي هو عليه الان
المرحله اللي هي مبكرا جدا
يعتقد انه سيكون سيقطع الطريق على الاخرين
وهناك من يعتقد انه يمكن ان يستطيع ان
يفعل ذلك اذا كان هناك عدد كبير من
المرشحين جمهوريين فتتوزع الاصوات وعندها
يستطيع
النسبه التي تدعمه عاده وهي بين حوالي 30
ل 35 او 40% يمكن ان ينجح في الحصول على
على همم على تاجيل الحزب له ولكن هناك قول
في امريكا ان سنتين او سنه في الحياه
السياسيه هو عمر فالكثير الامور سوف تحدث
واعتقد ان هذه المرحله السنتين ستكون
معركه معارك قاسيه داخل الحزب الجمهوري
وايضا بين الحزب الجمهوري والحزب
الديمقراطي داخل الكونغرس وفي الساحه
السياسيه الامريكيه فلا اعتقد ان مبكر جدا
ان نعلم ماذا ستكون عليه الامور ولكن همم
كان همم امس واضحا ان الرئيس سابق ترامب
لم يعد لديه الزخم الذي كان لديه لم يعد
اليه الدعم الذي كان
الذي يحتاجه لكي يحصل على تاييد حزبه وعلى
الفوز في الانتخابات فالواضع مبكرا الان
هو بكر كثيرا في اعلان عن ترشيح نفسه
على نتائج من الان وحتى سنتين امور تتغير
ربما في ايام احيانا بحكم ما يحصل في
الولايات المتحده والعالم همم السفيره ما
المدلله السفيره اللبنانيه السابقه في
الامم المتحده من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا على
هذه المشاركه معنا ليله تحياتي اليك
اعتبرت اسرائيل الهجوم بمسيره على ناقله
نفط قبلات ساحل عمان
الايراني بحسب ما نقلت صحيفه طائرات
حملت ايران مسؤوليه الهجوم على الناقله
وقال مستشار الامن القومي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ينضم الينا من المنامه المتحدث بسم الله
اسطول الخامس للبحريه الامريكيه اهلا بك
معنا سيد هوكينز وابدا معك باخر المعلومات
التي وصلتكم والتي باتت لديكم بشان هذا
الحادث
اياسو
تمام تمام
مسيرات ومن خلال التكنولوجيا التي كانت
تنشرها في المنطقه وتسبب بحاله من عدم
الصقر وهو مصدر خالق كبير
ليله الامس من شخص وفي حقيقه الامر العام
الماضي وفي شهر يوليو اين همم
شخص همم
هذه العمليات لابد ان تتوقف ان نشعر
بالخلق الكبيره ولهذا السبب فاننا ملتزمون
بالكامل للحفاظ
على حضور بحرين مستمر مع الشركائنا في
المنطقه في المجال البحريه
ااا رفع حاله تاهب في المنطقه بحريه على
الاقل مع استمرار الاستهدافات الايرانيه
للملاحه
ويهاف تو ميجر
القوات المشتركه وهي الاكبر متعدده
الجنسيات منطقه من حيث طبيعه شركاتها وهي
الاكبر في العالم همم ثلاثه واربعون دوله
التزمت بالحفاظ على القواعد والانظمه
المعمول بها في مجال البحار ولدينا ايضا
تحالف اضافي اخر اخر يسمى همم
الذي يعنى بخفر سوا سوا حلوه وهو مؤلف من
عشره دول
في الحفاظ على منطقه
الشركات والعمل فيما بيننا
للمستوى الاقليمي لتلك الشركات وتقديم
الردع المطلوب وكذلك اعاده الطم انا بشان
الشحن التجاري بمعنى اننا ملتزمون بالحفاظ
على حريه الملاحه البحريه
والتجاره العالميه يمكنها ان تسير بصوره
سلسه تلك المنطقه ااه سؤالي لك كان هل
هناك ما يستدعي رفع حال التاهب
نعم نعم
وعلينا ان نعير انتباهها كبيرا لاي انشطه
تزعزع الاستقرار وفي وخاصه في مناطق
المياه المحيطه وهذا ما نفعله وتفعله
البحريه الامريكيه
في الاسبوع الماضي
المتفجره التي تعدل اكبر من نوعها من همم
مركبات
الامونيوم التي يمكنها ان تصنع متفجرات
فهذا خطر كبير
وكانت عمليه اعتراض مهمه ايقافتها لان تلك
الانواع
الشرعيه عبر البحر عبر البحار وهي غير
قانونيه
كبيره خلال العامين الماضيه وكذلك ايضا
قمنا بعمليات ضبط تصل قيمتها الى ملايين
الدولارات واس- من المخدرات والاسلحه
الكبيره ومكونات التي يمكن ان تستخدم في
صواريخ التي تطلق على المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ودوله الامارات العربيه المتحده
في مطلع الى العام الحالي لذا اننا نركز
بشده على التحديات والتحديدات التي
تعترضوا المنطقه
وجلها من بعضها من ايران وسوف نستمر
الاستقرار في المياه
التقنيات التي تستخدمها ايران في هذا
المجال خاصه لجهه المسيرات هل تلحظون
تطورا ايه فيها وبالتالي يستدعي عملا
مضاعفا وخاصا
لمحاوله مواجهتها
في القدرات
اه الخاصه بايران في ما يتعلقوا بزياده
عدد الصواريخ البالستيه وصواريخ الكروز
والمسيرات الجويه ونحن لم نرى فقط زياده
في حجم القدرات والكميه بالايضا راينا
انتشارا كبيرا لها وتحويلها وتحويلها هذه
التكنولوجيا الى وكلاء ايران الامر الذي
بدوره يخلق المزيد من حاله عدم الاستقرار
في المنطقه هذا مساء امر يثير الخلق لنا
ان نركز على المعالجتها
الطرق التي نقوم
من خلال تعزيز
الدوليه الذين يلعبون دورا اساسا في
المنطقه بالاضافه الى ذلك
التكنولوجيه تلك التي لا تحتاج الى تشغيل
من قبل
اي شخص هي مسيرات بحيث التي يمكن ان
تشغلها في المناطق البحريه نرى هذه
التهديدات بصوره مبكره ولعل هذا يدفعنا
لاختبار قوتنا ومعرفه اين يجب ان تكون
وعلى مقربه من حدوث تلك المخاطر وهذا سوف
يحمل في طياته تاثيرا بادعي وسوف يقوم
بحمايه البحار وهذا هو جوهر تركيزنا في
الفتره الحاليه شكرا جزيلا لوجودك معنا
الليله على اثر هذه العمليه الايرانيه همم
المتحدث باسم الاسطول الخامس للبحريه
الامريكيه تم هوكنز من المنامه تحياتنا
اليك
الى ملف الاحتجاجات الايرانيه الان حيث لا
بادره لاطفاء نار هذه الاحتجاجات سوى
بحمله القمع والاعدام هكذا يرى معارض
السلطات الايرانيه على الاقل لكن بينما
تعتمد الحكومه الايرانيه هذه الطريقه في
التظاهرات التي عمت انحاء البلاد وخرجت عن
السيطره اضاف المحتجون الى قائمه شعاراتهم
المناهضه للحكومه عباره تقول انهم
سيقاتلون حتى الموت وحتى يستعيدوا ايران
النظام الذي بدا بوصف المحتجين شغب
والمخربيبين احدث اوصافه ليقضي عليهم
بطريقه اخرى نعدهم بالمفسدين في الارض بل
باعداء الله كذالك ثقه هذه الاتهامات امام
القضاء الذي اصدر ثلاثه احكام اضافيه
بالاعدام بحق من وصفهم بمرتكبي الاعمال
الاعمال الشغب في الاحتجاجات التي اعقبت
مقتل الفتاه العشرينيه
يعيد التاريخ نفسه اذا في الذكرى السنويه
الثالثه الاحتجاجات عام 2019 والتي لم يقل
التعامل معها عن قمع اليوم فتقارير
المعارضه تقول ان الف شخص فقد حياتهم
بينما الالاف اعتقلوا حينها لليوم الثاني
على التوالي يدخل المدنيون الى ساحات
الاسواق والى السوق الكبير او البازار في
طهران فيجدون ابواب المحل التجاريه مو
صداقه بسبب الاضرابات
توسع نطاق هذه الاضرابات اذا من العاصمه
طهران ليصل الى عشرات المدن من بينها مشهد
وصفهان وسندج وبندر عباس وكريم نجاح
[موسيقى]
اذا حمى الاحتجاجات وصلت الى كبرى الاسواق
ما الذي يعني ذلك اغلاق ابواب العمل في
بازارات معروفه يشفي بان الانتفاضه مستعصب
الاقتصاد الايراني فالاسواق الكبيره ما هي
الا سريان رئيسي يضخ الاموال للدوله اي
انها ايضا رمز للاستقرار المادي بالتالي
فان اصحاب هذه المتاجر ونعني رجال الاعمال
الكبار انضموا الى ركب الاحتجاج بطريقتهم
هم ايضا ماعدوا يثقونا بالحكومه وانقلبوا
عليها لحسب احدث حصيله نشرتها منظمه
الحقوقيه قتل مالا يقل عن 340 متظاهرا
خلال حمله القمع وتشمل الحصيله الصادره عن
هذه المنظمه القتلى في محافظه سيستان
لوستان المتاخمه لباكستان والذين لا يقلوا
عددهم عن 100 و23 شخصا
ووفقا لارقامها اعتقلت قوات الامن
الايرانيه ما لا يقل عن 15,000 شخص وهو
رقم تنفيه طهران
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وصل ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان
رئيس وزراء كوريا الجنوبيه
لولي العهد السعودي خلال ثلاث سنوات ومن
المنتظر ان تكون عديد الملفات الاقتصاديه
الكبرى اعلى جدول الزياره بحضور كبرى شركه
الكوريه ورجال الاعمال وذلك لمناقشه فرص
الاستثمار في السعوديه
ذكر عصافير سعودي في العاصمه الكوريه
الجنوبيه سول للعربيه انه سيقام على هامشي
زياره ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان الى كوريا الجنوبيه منتدى للاستثمار
بحضور كبرى شركات الكوريه ورجال الاعمال
وذلك لمناقشه فرص الاستثمار في السعوديه
سوف يقام ايضا منتدى الاستثمار على هامش
هذه الزياره
لجذب الشركات
ورجال الاعمال
في لقاء مباشر مع شركات
ورجال اعمال سعوديين ليتم بحث ومناقشه همم
فرص الاستثمار في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لذلك هناك حماس كبير من الشركات
الكوريه في الدخول في شركات استراتيجيه
واستثماريه وتجاريه مع القطاع الخاص في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تربته سعوديه وكوريا الجنوبيه علاقات
المتينه انتزت بالتوافق والتنسيق على
المستويات السياسيه والاقتصاديه كافه
نتعرف على بعض من محطاتها وما حققته خلال
الاعوام ال 60 الماضيه
[موسيقى]
60 عاما عمرو علاقات السعوديه وكوريا
الجنوبيه جمعتهما توافقات عده في الكثير
من الجوانب السياسيه والاقتصاديه
والثقافيه فمنذ نشاتها في العام
1962 كان للبلدين محطات مهمه اقتصاديا
وتجاريا حيث شهدت العلاقات المشتركه منذ
بدايتها اتفاقيات ومذكرات تفاهم اسهم في
جعل السعوديه من اوائل الشركاء التجاريين
لكوريا الجنوبيه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
حيث كان من اهمها تاسيس اللجنه السعوديه
الكوريه المشتركه فيما شكل اطلاق رؤيه
السعوديه الكوريه 20 30 في العام 2017
نقطه تحول مهمه لتاسيس مرحله شراك اكبر في
قطاعات الاستراتيجيه منها النقل والطاقه
والاتصالات حيث تستهدف كوريا الجنوبيه من
خلالها ان تكون من ابرز الشركاء المساهمين
في تحقيق رؤيه السعوديه 2030
في العام 20 21 بلغ حجم التبادل التجاري
بين السعوديه وكوريا الجنوبيه نحو 26
مليار دولار في مسجل الميزان التجاري
فائضا لصالح السعوديه بقيمه 19 مليار
دولار
وعلى الصعيد الاستثمارات تعمل شركه سعوديه
مختلفه في السوق الكوريه من ابرزها
استثمار والمقو السعوديه حيث تعمل من
خلالها اربعه مشاريع وشركتين تتجاوز
قيمتها الخمس مليارات دولار وايضا سابك
تعمل بحجم استثمارات بلغ مليار دولار
وفي الجهه المقابله بلغ عدد الاستثمارات
الكوريه في السعوديه
132 استثمارا باجمالي راس المال يتجاوز
ثلاث مليارات في قطاعات منها التعدين
والكهرباء والغاز
زياره ولي العهد السعودي ستشهد توقيع
اتفاقيات وشركات مع شركات كوريه والسعوديه
في مختلف المجالات مع توقعاتنا بجذب
المزيد من الاستثمارات الكوريه الى
المملكه ميسون ويهد العربيه سول كوريا
الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]
وقف العربيه 360 ايضا قمه المناخ المقبله
قد تقام في الامازون رئه الارض التي لا
تتوقف عن المحاربه من اجلنا ولا نتوقف نحن
عن تجريدها من سلاحها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ودورها
نتيجه توصلت اليها استراليا بعد عمليه
قرصنه الكترونيه كبيره تعرضت لها استراليا
اعلنت قبل ايام عن تمكن قراصنه رؤوس على
الارجح من اختراق الملايين الملفات في
استراليا لشركه الاتصالات المحليه اوبتوس
وشركه التامين العملاقه ميديا بانك الجمعه
اعلنت شرطه الاستراليه ان قراصنه روسيا
يقفون وراء الهجوم الالكترونيه الذي طالع
قرابه 10 ملايين مشترك في شركه التامين
الصحي ومن بينهم رئيس الوزراء في وقت لاحق
نشر المخترقون بعض البيانات المسروقه على
منتدى على الانترنت المظلم كما يطلق عليها
او الدارك ويب وطلبه بعشره دولار كافيديا
لوقف تسريب المعلومات وزيره الامن
السيبراني الاستراليه كلاير اونيل تعاهدت
بعد الهجومين الالكترونيين باختراق
المتسللين الذين تمكنو من سرقه معلومات
الملايين في استراليا واشنطن بوست ترى حتى
تحليلا التقطت في خلاله بخبراء بشؤون
التقنيه قالوا ان الدول بامكانها قرصنه
القراصنه الا ان الامر سيكون سلاحا ذا
حدين احد الخبراء قال انه ليس من السهل
استهداف الدوله التي ينتمي اليها القراصنه
وفي هذه الحاله الدوله هي روسيا التي بحسب
الخبير التقني تتساهل مع عمليات القرصنه
او تتغاضى عنها تماما بحسب واشنطن بوست من
الامور التي ينبغي على الدول اخذها بعين
الاعتبار استهداف القراصنه بشكل مباشر
والتاكد من عدم وقوع هدف بريء ضحيه لان
هذا قد يسبب مشاكل لدول حليفه خاصه اذا
تسلل القراصنه من ثغره لدوله حديثه ليضرب
عبرها
اضافت صحيفه ان استراليا تواجه الخصومه
انفسهم في الفضاء الالكترونيه الذين كافحت
الولايات المتحده لمواجهتهم الا ان
استراليا تفعل ذلك مع قوه الكترونيه اصغر
بكثير وهو امر يبدو ان استراليا تدركه
الصعبه
[موسيقى]
شكرا لمحمد فيديو اليوم من المكسيك ماتت
فريده كلبه البحريه الاشهر في المكسيك
بطله البحث عن ضحايا زلزال 2017 فريدا
كانت تملك سيره ذاتيه ربما لا يملكها ذوي
الرتب الرفيعه في البحريه المكسيكيه فقد
اسهمت في عمليات الانقاذ في زلازل هيتي
والاكوادور
الى انفجارات في بعض الثقافات قد يشعر
البعض بالاستياء من تشبيهه بالكلب لكن في
المكسيك يشعرون بالفخر انشوبه
وفي تصريح اليوم البرازيل عادت الى الساحه
الدوليه وستطلب استضافه مؤتمر المناخ في
2025 في الامازون التصريح للرئيس
البرازيلي المنتخب لويس سيلفا خلال قمه
المناخ الحاليه في شرم الشيخ المصريه
اختيار لولا دا سيلفارا رائع بالفعل ستعقد
خدمه المناخ القادمه في الامازون رئه
الارض فهذه الغابه اكبر بئر للكربون في
العالم باشجارها التي تقترب من 400 مليار
شجره لكن الامازون اصلا في طريقها لنقطه
لا عوده بسبب تغير المناخ وايادي البشر
نقطه لن نكون بعدها قادرين على التحدث عن
غابات الامازون وانما في افضل تقدير
سافانا لامازون
صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 في العالم
المتقدم يتسابقون الاختراع سيارات افخم
اسرع اذكى كي يعيش الناس حياه اسهل لكن في
الكونغو وديمقراطيه يتسابقون كي يخترعوا
شيئا يجعلوا الحياه تطاق لا شيء فيها مريح
ولا ذكي ولا شيء فيه يدور سوى عجلتين لكنه
سيسهم في جعل الرحله اقصر وفي جعل الحمل
اخف ليس لتوفير الوقت للراحه وانما
لتوفيره لرحله جديده لمثل هذه العيون
المجهده الراحه قد ياتي بعد هجره
نهايه العربيه 360 ولكن اخبار الساعه التي
تنقطع من العربيه الان مع صهيب شراير
وماذا لديك مساء الخير طاهر جوله سريعه
شامله ومتنوعه على اهم اخبار اليوم في
الصداره معلومات تنقلها اكسس ان اداره
فايدن ابلغت الحكومه العراقيه الجديده
بانها لن تتعامل مع وزراء ينتمون لمنظمات
ارهابيه تمام
[موسيقى]